get experience not enough kids are  willing to work for free or very little  to learn getting your hands dirty under  your fingernails  it's the game I just don't know what  else to say to me that is the number one  thing that blows my mind that kids don't  want to work for it so one learn your  craft to pay attention to your friends  the young are the future and if you  notice trends like oh they don't use  email you can learn from that or endure  watching a lot of YouTube so the two  biggest things are stop being soft and  start actually working and getting your  hands dirty in the thing that you love  and number two pay attention to trends  around your friends